bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono farisei e come sempre siamo
in un nuovo video ma prima di cominciare
l'epicità che state per vedere volevo
ringraziare la microsoft ha inviato
questo joystick incredibile che ai tasti
davanti e figli che si staccano
e sono magnetici che è incredibile cioè
dei tasti anche dietro io a malapena
conosco quelli davanti quindi quelli
dietro
lasciamoli perdere tanti ragazzi su jan
force che l'ultimo episodio avevo fatto
congela andrea non aveva sbloccato tutti
i personaggi
oggi invece sbloccati tutti possiamo
giocare ragazzi forse sto per poter
utilizzare gli uv o maledizione questo
era l'unico personaggio che volevo usare
il tutto jean force e non era sbloccato
all'inizio
iamm e quindi oggi new york lo
utilizziamo però a fare una partita
contro computer vediamo cosa esce fuori
yuki il primo personaggio in assoluto
poi abbiamo ce ne sono un miliardo
yusuke ora mesh togo minore chi apprezza
quello maggiore come mezzo ma cotto
ciccio ci voglio scissi poi ragazzi tra
tutti dovrei scegliere un altro
personaggio altri due persone
giustamente dio dio scegliamo dio perché
dio io penso sia all asta ci sono quelli
di giorgio tutti ci sono in realtà il
problema è che non sapevi ore 00 di ieri
e lo zodiaco
ma dai no scherzavo con gli open cast su
save dai scattava la pegasus sirio
non lo so e freezer a caso a tifà
scegliere anche la mappa va bene allora
zona allenamento nuova zelanda giappone
messico italia c'erano l'italia ciampi
chateau addosso allora facciamo un
giappone è let's go gli uni contro
pegasus mamma mie cavaliere lo zodiaco
riguarda voglio da piccoli si è fatto
non ero neanche dalla mia generazione
della della generazione con la prima
della minima quindi già un miracolo che
li abbia visti gli ho detto allora per
fermo che non suoi comandi fermo fermo
fammi capire o sbagliato ho evocato dio
sembra una bestemmia non ami caricare
allora attacca mago nero o demonio e
freezer freezer contro yuki frizzante
vagone rovai ma provai bravo ma non ero
bravo non conto niente picchia lo
picchia lo picchiano
bravo ma non ero così si fa bravo
caricati yuki caricati scusa giovane
maga nera che è sempre stata una gran
gnocca aggiungerei menaye menaye
fortissimo
bravissimo il momento i giochi al
momento è il momento quello che
aspettava da una vita sla in third
regole ma come posso per non usare slia
forse deve colpirmi un tot prima a
sedere colpire 28 ragazzi non lo so
comunque va bene
raga sono veramente scarsi personaggi
però devo aumentare il livello di
difficoltà dalla stessa macchina e me la
voglio dire no mi ha fatto malissimo
scherzavo va benissimo livello di
difficoltà
lei farlo posso usare perché ogni cosa
ha fatto pescare perché una carta fresco
una carta è una mossa che fa questa cosa
qui perché mai pesca una carta dovrebbe
evocare delle carte che lo picchiano
aumento di attacco va bene l'attacco
demonio è così io voglio usare dio
fatemi sarei dio un attimo a tempo
scaduto a ok mi sa che quinto ragazzi
allora non so riuscito a usare il jean
king secondo round scusate non ho capito
bene agli ammiragli e mail ai è che
figata incredibile il suo gioco non solo
capire come si fa perché ci sono un
miliardo milioni tasche mente che non
non conosco sono dio
vai dio scacco matto no scherzavo
inutile inutile
ma ho colpito anno non ho colpito
nessuno mai fatto a caso è proprio per
questo che si chiama inutile inutile
perché lo fai aran
poi c'è perfetto che in teoria è questo
mamma mia ciao freezer
io ho fatto delle cose strane e poi c'è
the world
gli ho fatto male mi sa che io ho fatto
male
cambiamo 0 bravo 0 complimenti fumare
del becco avevo già stato controllato
miss a 3000 mondi sia una pizza con
patatine caviale e grazie sei stato così
per un'ora e mezza bravo bravo zoro
bravo e dovresti fare visto che c'è
anche dopo tremila monili fila troviamo
in c'è anche 3.000 milioni di mondi
voglio usare quella visto che quella di
prima ci ha messi ore ha fatto di
colpirlo subito tempo scaduto vinto io
un vero duellante non sapeva solo la
fortuna di avere il coraggio di credere
nelle sue carte ragazzi credete nel
cuore delle carte mannaia credeteci
allora termina incontra mente un po la
difficoltà e cambiano i personaggi
tranne yugi quello dopo ancora tenerlo
volevo fare sly fair drago del cielo yu
gi oh contro vegeto lo voglio vedere
ragazzi questa veramente strano e posso
evocare mago nero che mi pare l'attacca
mi ha ok pensavo solo a cambiare
personaggio ma fallo subito porca vacca
complimenti si vede che ha un po
aumentato la difficoltà
vorrei usare il driver drago del cielo
se è possibile magari era li sto usando
tutti l'unico che vorrei usare quello
che non mi sblocca bravo che getta bravo
fatti valere
ma se io che il mio personaggio tipo
diverso la sl c'era l'ultima camera
solare tipo ciao mi chiamo cura pica
quando incazzato si fa sentire la mia
mia sola o che proprio mi aiuti broken
bray yuki cambia iudica mi aiutino non
voglio né voglio yu gi oh scambiano
cambio di nuovo i performers per fonte
met mazza che takata in bocca
qualcosa mi dice che più forte lei di
sly per drago del cielo che però
cambiare di nuovo progetto perché sly
fair non me lo fa mentre che strano
forse devo aumentare ancora a livello di
difficoltà perché deve mettermi in
difficoltà per evocarlo è poi scaduto
perfetto va beh mi son riuscito neanche
stavolta aumento il livello di
difficoltà ancora ragazza valiamo
sull'esilio naruto si naruto goku
mannaia oggi ma che c'è il mio cervello
è casuale
gli altri tutti casuali prego la mia
esca uno dei miei e facciamo san
francisco
cavolo yu gi oh contro rufy e anche in
giro e coloranti non lo so io c'ho
trunks perfetto è uscito trunks che non
è male però vedere se ne scrivo che ha
aumentato ancora a livello di difficoltà
perché probabilmente per evocare sly
fair deve colpirmi un sacco di volte il
nemico età ok petto la partenza è buona
la presenza buona vinco io ragazzi ve lo
dico già ciao mamma mia mago nero quanto
cazzuto buche il successo
goku e uscito a caso va bene ai ragazzi
sta recuperando come si vede che
aumentata la difficoltà ma attenzione
eccole cos'hai per cypher ciao ciao
fammi vedere la potenza mamma mi era la
mia carta preferita e non l'ho mai avuta
mylos uscito a trovarla mamma come lo
spaccato anche in giro il chino per chi
non lo sapesse è unanime
è molto vecchio avete presente il meme
quello di nani mussini viene da che in
giro c'è un po di scuola di me niente
ormai l'ho vista la roba quindi host di
lanci a genchi dama o fai il colpo
furioso dopo un furioso e farlo però
bravo coop non so come ringraziarti
camera me almeno quello
picchia lo piccolo mammamia al rock
quanto disappointed c'è una foto niente
di buono l'ho battuto per un niente male
ho fatto cose non sono anche come cambia
la veloce bravissimo super spera gen
chinavano scherzare
non so se lo becco non lo so hanno preso
non l'ho preso neanche per sbaglio però
va perche l'ho mancato tantissimo questa
volta l'ho preso in pieno
bayu chi tocca a the change allora ce
trans e ancora scusatemi tax franks non
ho idea di che cosa faccia sai però
grazie per le botte in faccia grazie
mille davvero non solo ringraziarti
attacco processo pendente supersonico
però magari in faccia lui sarebbe più
utile che dici trans l'impatto finale
questo me lo ricordo c'era anche in
69 bruciante attacco presente quando io
cucino poi concluderla con dio vi prego
fa che sto vincendo si spera ma io
chissà come lo sai fare tu come lo sai
fare tu yugi chiudi la chiudeva così non
mi deludere sly perth non è vero l'ho
mancato veramente non ci crederai l'ho
mancato no dai
alla fine brava brava ma che lei a
pranzo nella carriera bravissima pesca
una carta yu gi oh battuto ragazzi
sempre credere nel cuore le carte sempre
credere nel cuore delle carte signori la
potenza abbiamo volevo jean force per
questo quindi ragazzi spero che mi sia
piaciuto
ringrazio tutti ringrazio kokorin caso
trans ma soprattutto yuki per aver
partecipato a questo video presente
ragazzi subito piaciuto sul momento mi
piace anche vari social comitato da
descrizione se nostra doversi discrete e
noi ci vediamo l'anno prossimo duello
birds
[Musica]